Okay, let's look at a couple more operators. I'm going to switch over
and use the Mongo shell for some of this. This is a
console application that ships with the database, and it provides a great
interface for exploring MongoDB's query language. So, the first thing that I
need to do is switch into the right database which I've already
done here with use examples. Now I'm just going to do a find
against the whole collection and we see a whole bunch of documents
scroll by. Okay, so as we've discussed, some documents will contain fields
that others do not. In our cities' collection, for many
cities, especially those that are less important or simply smaller, much
of the detail is missing. For example, a small town
in the U.S. state of Iowa where I used to live
is going to have much less detail than let's say
Berlin, London, or other major cities. Mongo DB allows you to
query based on the structure of information that's in the documents,
as well as their values. So let's take a look at
an example. So I happen to know that relatively few
documents have a field for government type. It's useful to
know what type of government a particular city has, but
it's only the larger cities that tend to have this
field. MongoDB provides an operator called Exists that allows us
to retrieve documents based on whether or not documents contain
a particular field. And the value for Exists is whether
we want documents that contain the field, or those that don't.
In this case, I want to find documents that do
have a governmentType field. Oop and you see what
happened there is I forgot to close the query
document. So, let's go back and do that, and there
we go. And let's do a count here. And
of the 20,000 documents in this collection, a relatively
small number contain this field. We can do the
inverse query and see we get a much larger number.
Let's take a look at one of these documents. Here
I'm going to use pretty to make it more human readable.
Okay, so let's go back to the documents that actually
contain this field. And again I'll make em pretty. Okay,
so this happens to be the city of Lansing, Michigan,
and you can see there's a quite a bit of
detail here. Okay. Now, what we can do is contrast
this with documents that don't have this field, and it just
happens to be the case that this document
is conveniently, for example purposes, much more sparse. So
the Exists Operator allows us to do queries and
asks some questions about the structure of a document.